all right brett yes brett uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
i was born in austin minnesota
i got my ged in albany county
correctional facility
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid
yes it did
and then my dad got in the hormone
strike in
the midwest so that kind of messed us up
the wet strike
hormel the pig plant right
because like she was a stay-at-home mom
right
and then all of a sudden he had to you
know
go to school and get re-educated and all
that sort of stuff
and how would you describe your
childhood
i described myself as a loner i didn't
like those in school
i didn't really like
we moved around way too much no i
don't really like fit in anywhere did
you make friends anywhere you lived
i met a few friends yeah but i wasn't
like
outgoing or played football or
um you know the
activities with the school or [ __ ] stuff
like that
and
why was it that you didn't finish high
school
i got kicked out of the work program
for selling lsd
and then my parents moved and i tried
giving that a whack
and i just fell apart
and actually it followed me there now i
think about it
it followed me there so you got involved
with drugs
at a very early age yeah how did that
happen
i thought lsd was the best drug on earth
became my life
14. you started using lsd at 14.
how often would you use lsd it got to be
like
probably about every other day
for how long oh i'm saying
a long time there was ecstasy and all
this
other stuff dmt
and what are you using today speed
uh methadone xanax
and you've been living here in the
tenderloin for how long
since 2000 about 21 years
do you have kids of your own
i have one son i'm on the parent by his
choice
you were married no never and i
checked this story out i was in jail and
i could have got away with
not signing the birth certificate
i went ahead and signed it
my dad said i was the stupidest man on
earth
have you ever spent any time with your
son no
when when he turned six uh out here i
called him he's like don't ever call me
again how does that make you feel
very angry angry at yourself
or angry at him
and myself but uh
i'm sad
and i can't get no drugs out here for my
my
mental you know deficiency
is [ __ ] what drugs would help you
oh president lamb um
things like that what is your mental
deficiency
i have uh well obviously i have a
traumatic brain injury
i have a crush tip a fake hip
what was the brain injury from from the
impact from
the car hidden in the tree
how old were you and that happened
know that i was uh
30 something were you high or drunk or
anything like that
voted loaded yeah my good buddy took me
to cleaners
he sued me through the the grocery store
he sued
everybody
where are you living today you're in a
tent no i i
thank the lord i have the elm hotel
so you got a roof over your head have
you been homeless before
yeah yeah okay
yes sir and how do you support yourself
now
um i try to do
a little bit of a
shoplifting
and you'll sell it to a fence and or
i'll try to sell
drugs but people make them do iso drugs
it's the truth one day i couldn't get
off a bag of speed
and uh they got mad at me
what emotions do you deal with you've
been through a lot in your life it
sounds like
anger a lot of
depression
painting you feel shame as well
yeah a little bit listen to this story
my kid's grandma she had adopted me to
say i wouldn't let you on my
property
and the [ __ ] flies out here and stays
in my room
how does that make you feel awful
and i paid her for rent i paid her 250
for rent
[Music]
do you believe in karma yeah i believe
in karma but i'm
uh any i believe in the antichrist
i believe in karma for sure yeah
but you do those we'll come back to you
what events in your life would affect
your karma
what effects like karma what events in
your life would it would affect your
karma
let's see i smashed the [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] out of my friend
in that car accident i robbed this guy
up here
for 300 and some bucks that was pretty
battering
um what else have i done
maybe not being there for your son
yeah but he told me i should be there
why do you think that would have been
was it because you're using drugs
i think i think grandma caused him
and then she just started she she just
said i
did a coaching
what's been the hardest thing you've had
to go through in your life
uh 36 months incarceration
what was that for just [ __ ] drinking
drugs stolen car
setting up for an eight ball which
didn't exist
i i found it the next day
living the life that you've lived with a
lot of debauchery it sounds like
what do you think put you on that path
you think your
your parents your friends
well i can't blame nobody but myself i'd
like to blame a lot of people
you know what i mean like it's just
it's difficult it's good you take
responsibility for it
is it true you know it may
follow a few beers back and oh it says
some people would say you're a fuck-up
am i a fuck-up
i mean i work and i work as a mason
you've had jobs yeah in connecticut
yeah blowing insulation if you're going
to do that
yeah that's hard man it's getting money
so you've had jobs before yeah had jobs
before
then this car accident
painted
your name wash dishes
so you've tried i've tried
i have no teeth my mom
you've been in love before yeah
yeah twice
really low
what was the best time of your life best
time in my life
was when i was high and making lots of
money
and it was fun
oh dear you think you'll ever get off
the streets
away from drugs
yeah you do how old are you um
right now i'm 48.
no i'm i'm thinking about going to santa
cruz
because listen this i get these voices
they're
telling me to move
what do you think about that sir yeah
well i mean there's drugs in santa cruz
too
there's drugs everywhere so sometimes a
change of environment
new friends new people around you can be
helpful but what about these voices
though
oh the voices well i suspect
a lot of the hallucinogenics you're
playing around with might be bringing
those voices out
[Music]
i've never heard voices they're is
i want to cut your dick off
it's scary yeah no but i mean
the things you're playing around with
affect your brain right
and maybe you're hearing things that
aren't really happening but
but they seem real it scares the [ __ ]
out of me
it does i mean i i have to admit it
it does more
people don't say that do they no
do you think there's something about
this life with very little
responsibility that makes it
hard to leave hard to change
yeah it's just you know i got sucked
back right back here
i thought it'd be you know cool and
things you know things would be cool
but it hasn't been yeah it's a rough
life
i mean i've got my uh
i got thrown on the middle of the month
when i paid rent
by the 5-0
i've gotten uh a bunch of
great stories
what do you worry about
uh what do i worry about being uh
murdered
a friend of mine said i'm gonna be
gunned down in the streets
are you religious do you believe in god
no maybe i should start for you
god is going to help you what's the most
important lesson you've learned
in my whole life or today
in your life
take advantage of a good situation
and don't stop and today
be friendly and boom
excellent i like it brett thank you so
much for talking with me
you're welcome and good luck with
wherever your life goes from here
you got it thanks
you